why can't you have a 12-inch nose
because then it's a foot
just cause i'm curious i'm gonna play
the where's hari krishnan
here we go oh
it's one of these it's uh trwitzki's
how do i do this i need to play knight
c3 right
there's a whole wikipedia article about
this position
so for those i can try and explain this
for those who don't know first of all
two knights
versus a lone king is a draw just
theoretical like you can't force mate
but two knights
and king vs king and pawn is winning
if the pawn is blockaded
uh there's some like weird
series of squares it might be
it might i forget how it goes but the
the move to play is 94 so i blockade the
pawn
um i've never actually studied this
position
i know it's winning though if the pawns
on the center you can block hate on the
fourth rank
pretty sure i'll have to find the
wikipedia
article but i'm gonna try and uh i guess
i'll try and figure this out
on my own the the main issue is the 50
move rule
okay so i obviously have to like get
this knight and king into play
let's develop this knight first
so basically if if i'm not mating by
move 51
and black hasn't moved upon or i haven't
taken the pawn it's going to be a draw
okay this is going to be interesting
so i think i would like the knights to
defend each other the question is i play
this or is this move
but maybe that's okay because i'm
controlling e6
and um
yeah it's gonna get like really weird
because uh this knight can't really move
if this light moves upon pushes and
if i ever take it it's a draw
but now okay now the key moves here i
move up it's not stalemate
i'm controlling these two squares
i have a vague memory hans neiman had
this in a game
in like an over-the-board tournament
game and he won
and i wrote about it for uschefs.org
i'll have to find the the article
oh chad is in emote only mode oh all
that chat speak
sorry chat your your freedom of speech
is being
toyed around with okay so the knights
coordinate really nicely here
let's uh
play this move
i mean most natural right
i know the end goal is to basically
stalemate the king
let the pawn push and then orchestrate
some mates
well i say stalemate the king i would
have to take away all the squares and
then allow the pawn to move
so for example this move
the pawn starts pushing
and there's no there's no real mate
how do i do this man
this is gonna take some
some magic maybe
so the king wants to come here and i
want to
trap it in this kind of quadrant
uh what to do knight here king here
i could also like make the king walk
this way
not sure though let's play this first at
least i'm controlling h4
it's only move 10. so i have i have
basically 40 moves
to kind of play around thank you like
ferrari
yeah after this game i'll have to show
the hans game and also
the wikipedia article but there's
something called troitsky's line
which is like um it basically explains
the theory of this position
okay i might have to start calculating
like knight g3
king here here
there's only f6 as well
and lights are so lights can be tricky
but sometimes they're also clumsy
so i'm debating whether to allow the
king to move that way
i have a bad feeling i already messed
this up though
[Music]
there there i do this
check like i want to move this knight
but i don't want to like allow the pawn
to move
so if i check here
and check king goes back
the king still made it another joke from
chat
no no no say to the chess streamer
answer how do you want your haircut
frozen
just kidding that joke isn't from chat
wait what
hi eric i enjoy the youtube videos i
just
discovered the love for chess and you
after i moved out of missouri
hope you enjoy your late night chess
sesh oh thank you i'm trying to
it's also kind of stressful because i'm
trying to focus
and chest is complicated
um
[Music]
play this move
play this move and we'll we'll see how
this goes would be like so obvious mate
in 26 come on
yeah i mean that the table base will
find force mates
i think a gm a gm would probably do this
better than me
though i don't know but this is the type
of position not too many
even like really strong players formally
study
yeah so i guess it's more of a question
where does my night want to be
in life
if i move back we repeat
so oh i have an idea okay i'm gonna move
this way
and then come around or move this way
depending
so this square is covered
but these squares wait
um
how do i control f1
okay we're gonna maneuver the knight
around
i i'm almost positive i'm wasting some
tempe here
but it's all with good intention
okay now i'm i have opposition on the
other side of the board
and i'm controlling f2 but the king yeah
the king's going to try and be slippery
we're going to keep the opposition
okay now i can play this move
going for knight f2
it's annoying because the pawn is is i
can never take the pawn and i can never
move to f4
i'm still managing to make some progress
kind of
i really want to use the other night
i don't want to run out of time either
so king hidden
there
i feel so close as well
[Music]
oh i can play this move oh let's go okay
this move didn't come to mind initially
it's so weird too because like you have
to use a different
kind of thought process did my opponent
just give me more time i guess
opponent did you have to think about
this position differently than
you do just other types of
chess positions
because it's more about
um like very precise like square control
and prophylaxis but now i have nice
coordination
controlling these squares and these
squares so the king's confined
to this sad box
the question is how do i make how do i
drive the king into the corner
and not stalemate it
probably like this
king has two legal moves
okay now i play this move controlling
the square
am i making progress
wait i have this move here here
here let's try this
it's a weird maneuver but i want to come
to e3
to then control f1 the timing has to
work out though
okay
i'm feeling good about this i'm feeling
like i have plenty of time as well
so the knights are like perfectly placed
controlling these two squares
and also g2 so now i can move the king
in further
we're basically shouldering out so king
can't move up it has to move back
and now
the question is how do i finish things
off
like other other types of end games i
just rely on
[Music]
um on patterns i've seen before
but i've never actually taken the time
to learn these sort of patterns
okay so i can check and then check here
we go
and then maneuver the night for mate
okay and knight f2 mate will be and this
so this is why it's so important that
black has a pawn
because you could force this position
without the pawn
but then there's no way to actually mate
without stalemating
um you need like the one extra kind of
waiting move
or not the waiting move but just uh the
tempo to maneuver
so the only legal move is pawnee iv
and then it's meat okay
that was satisfying
oh thanks chat for being so supportive
let's go yes first 11 boom thirst eleven
let's go thirst eleven oh
thanks thirsty monster
um yeah that's probably one of the more
difficult like theoretical end games
compared to like this is much more
difficult than like bishop nightmates
um so a few things to show first of all
uh troitsky line
yeah if you google uh troytskyline i
don't think i've i've actually read this
article in depth but this will
for an awesome checkmate oh thanks for
that
oh yeah thanks hari krishnan also for
the interesting challenge
hope you enjoyed i definitely did
thanks
yeah so this is basically the line where
the pawn
needs to be like the pawns beyond this
line
then it's drawn that was amazing
leech school oh thank you mr kilo
and cloud9 pt hey youtube
oh and rag to the rock and make your
goal
and incognito cheers bc end games are
hard
okay i'm gonna try and find that was
incredible to watch
hans amazing stuff champ
oh thank you
i'm on a journey to grind to 2000 this
year from 1300 blitz
amazing mate
ah so okay
i wrote an article um back in 2015
on it was after my best tournament ever
i got my
my fourth i am norm it was a tournament
that put me over the ratings i get the
im title
um and at the very end of the article i
mentioned
this hans neiman game but
it's not embedded
like i had embedded the game but now
it's just showing up as a number because
the uf chefs probably
redid their web stuff so let me see if i
can find this archive
that was great super gm stuff
oh thanks for that
i mean that's maybe more of a it's
probably
like a gm or master level
it was amazing oh i'm glad everyone so
many people are impressed
yeah it's not the type of end game you
really need to know
or understand to get good at chess but
i guess it's kind of a cool cool party
trick
good job making the horses maneuver to
beat the lone king the horses went nae
nae and said your checkmated buster porn
had to watch
oh thanks for that ah i really want to
find this game
hey i found it okay it's just a matter
of googling the right thing
so i have um chessgames.com link i'm
going to copy the link
and just bring it into uh
uh i guess alicia study
so it's it's one thing to do this online
but it's another thing to do this
in a real game because it's so rare that
this uh this actually happens in a real
game
okay so it's hans demon against
vignesh panchanathan um 2015
chicago open hans was just a
an even smaller child lee chess is love
lee chess is life
let's go let's go so this is a really
long game i just want to show
the end game um
that was like a crazy imbalance two
knights but black had like
four pawns on the king side and then
black started winning the pawns
yeah it was so crazy
this i'm realizing this is my second
time sharing a hans neiman game
on stream it makes for such good like
click bait though
so okay so hans got to this position
which uh
oh which table base tableway says a win
is prevented by the 50 move rule
so white's winning if the 50 move world
didn't exist
it's actually really funny but somehow
he's still mad show in
i'm going to turn off table base for now
whatever your title may say you're a
super gm bob rose into my eyes
you just call me bob rosen oh super gm
bob rosen
or bob rossen ah combining our names
so just to show okay hans had this
position um
according to the troitsky line
if the pawn so the f pawn needs to be on
f5
or uh or below but it was on f4 so if
it's on f4 then there's
no there's no like force win
but he still managed to win and it took
him
what was the last so the capture was on
move 56.
and he he ended up meeting on move man
move 104 so he just barely did it
um and this is probably more difficult
uh
because i had the center pawn but the
knight knight doesn't control
as many useful squares from f3
so yeah the moves look kind of random
but slowly but surely hans was able to
maneuver
and he kept maneuvering
yeah he did this like interesting uh
merry-go-round maneuver with a knight
and he kept being able to chase the king
because you want to chase it to like
this corner or this corner even
oh this corner
yeah this is really awesome and then
knight g5
so on move 102 the 50 move rule resets
because a pawn is moved
so from move 56 to 102
right yeah 56 to 102
so that was 46 moves
and there's so clutch because blacks on
the verge of queening with check
so um maybe i can
i mean having won that that game i get a
little taste of what hans
must have felt like with his beautiful
mates
did hans play knight a4 oh hans didn't
play knight a4 this game unfortunately
but that's okay okay so um
if this goes on youtube which maybe it
will it will go on youtube at some point
hope you guys enjoyed that hope that was
instructive i've actually never
yeah never got around to like teaching
this to anyone
so i hope people are enlightened and if
you have questions feel free to
[Music]
uh ask in the youtube comments
but please avoid ferocious debate
and i'll see you in the future